– Hi, Yara!
– Schau dir das Fahrrad an, Nico!
Wunderschön, oder?
– Na ja.
– Als ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin,
hatte ich auch so ein Fahrrad.
Es ist leider irgendwann kaputtgegangen.
– Ist das nicht auch kaputt?
– Was? Nein!
– Na ja, das Fahrrad sieht aus
wie Schrott.
– Er weiß ja nicht, was er da sagt.
Schrott!
– Nein, das weiß er wirklich nicht.
– Als ich in deinem Alter war, hab ich
von diesem „Schrott“ geträumt!
– Nico, das ist Otto.
Er sammelt Fahrräder.
– Ah, ich sammle viel zu viel.
Deshalb verkaufe ich manche Dinge
– am liebsten an so nette
Menschen wie Yara.
– Hallo, ich bin Nico, der Neffe von Yara.
Ich wollte nicht unhöflich sein.
– Ist schon gut.
– Was ist denn nun so besonders
an diesem Fahrrad?
– Das ist ein altes Fahrrad aus der
Deutschen Demokratischen Republik.
Seit der Wiedervereinigung gibt es
die DDR nicht mehr.
– Ja, das hab ich in der Schule gelernt.
– Ja, siehst du? Und dieses Klapprad wurde
in der DDR produziert,
als es das Land noch gab.
Dieser Typ wird heute gar nicht
mehr gebaut.
– Sagten Sie „Klapprad“?
– Ja, weil man es
zusammenklappen kann. Pass auf!
– Oh, Vorsicht! Nicht, dass es jetzt
noch kaputtgeht!
Dieses Fahrrad ist ein Stück Geschichte.
– Ja, so wie ich, wenn ich nicht
gleich was esse.
– Mach’s gut, Otto. Und vielen Dank!
Das Fahrrad bedeutet mir viel!
– Pass gut drauf auf!
– Tschüss!
Nico!
– Stabil ist es nicht.
Schrott!